foreign
okay
good afternoon everyone welcome to this
meeting of baber District Council
cabinet I'm councilor John Ward leader
of baby District castle and I'll be
chairing this meeting
may I remind you of some domestic
Arrangements please ensure that
microphones are turned off when not in
use
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversations whilst
others are speaking
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or Switched Off
finally we'll be using e-voting for this
meeting on the modern.gov app so please
can members make sure they are logged in
and ready to use the app
I'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you're also consenting to being recorded
by the council and to the possible use
of those images and sound recordings for
webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the Press are not lawfully excluded
I'll now move to the agenda item one
apologies for absence
thank you
item two to receive Declarations of
bikini other registerable or
non-registerable interest by members
councilor Osborne
[Music]
2013 stroke 43 sale of the land I don't
know that it's relevant but I am a
patient at Hardwick house
do I need to declare an interest
no no no
thanks anyway
item three
paper BCA 2237 to confirm the minutes of
the meeting held on the 5th of December
2022 and that you'll find those on pages
5 to 11 of your agenda pack just to go
through
um let me know if anyone has any points
regarding the accuracy of the minutes
on page five
a six
a seven
page eight
page nine
page 10.
and page 11.
if nobody wishes to say anything then
may I have a proposal please
cassarathi and a second uh councilor
Busby thank you
may we now have the vote thank you Chad
the vote is now
councilor melvisi I know you haven't
set up properly yet and
may I have your vote please
let's unanimous chairs thank you
item four to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme
not received item five questions by
counselors no not saved
item six matters referred by the
overview and scrutiny or joint audit and
standards committees there are no
matters to Preferred
thank you
item seven forthcoming decisions list
members of the cabinet does anyone have
any comments on the list
no
okay thank you
moving on then
item eight paper BCA 2238 the council
tax reduction working age scheme the
2023-24
I'd like to invite the cabinet member
for finance assets and Investments to
introduce the support Council of Busby
thanks John uh well we've been through
proposals and the recommendations and
what the scheme's about and why we're
doing it and the benefits in fact option
three was put out consultation and we've
had the results back and I'd just like
to
a few points none of the comments
or votes
suggested that we were going the wrong
direction to option three it was only a
fairly small survey unfortunately just
53 people
that they supported our views I think
there were a couple of interesting
um
comments and interesting responses to
the question I think the question six
which was about the proposed income Bans
showed that there is probably some work
that we can do going forward on that uh
maybe we haven't got that quite right
and I certainly would like to see
something done on that
and
um
obviously there is some confusion out
there as as to who pays what and why and
when so I think
there is a Target on our back to try and
get the communication better on on these
particular credit items
other than that I think the
consultation went well and that we can
now proceed so I'd like to recommend
that we go forward with the
recommendations three as in the paper
thank you
thank you Council Bluffs we may have a
second to please councilor Rafi
thank you right members of the cabinet
does anyone have any questions before we
enter into a debate
Council McLaren
[Music]
um so Council postpay I'm
need a bit of help with the detail with
these sort of Productions
um
I would like to know really about how
many soldiers are in seat are in receipt
of
CTR and UC of working age but are not
employed as opposed to those who are
employed and are in receipt of those
benefits is that is that available that
information
the number of people that are actually
going to be
the number of people that are going to
be affected by this
2250 I think it is according to the
paper
is that not the information that you
want
perfect enough
oh I don't have that figure to hand
say I can provide that but I don't have
it to hand at the moment
sorry thank you for having me I can get
that information and provide enough for
me yeah thank you
chair I would like to just add on to
that I think as a Cabinet member
I would welcome a member briefing on the
details of these the more detail and
we've got it's a very comprehensive
report
and um
I'm happy to support but I think some of
us and me personally would like a bit
more detail so that we can make really
accurate judgments when we're supporting
such a recommendation thank you okay
thank you Council Osborne do you have a
question
yeah thank you Mr chairman I know that
tomorrow Council have approved option
three can I assume that mid-suffolk
approved option three this morning
because life will be a lot easier for
the share Revenue Partnership if that's
the case
thank you
that was a yes yeah yeah there was a
there was another head so I assume that
was a yes yeah uh councilman crawl yeah
I mean just to add to that the fact is
that the shared Revenue partnership
operates very efficiently this will save
money
in fact it should probably save more
money in administration than it might
cost well certainly in that area and the
fact is that the shared revenues
Partnership if the other two councils
have agreed to it plus the fact it's a
good thing to do means that can be no
question in my mind but to support
option three
um that is straying a bit into debate
but we'll come back to that but that's
that's fine no problem but before we do
do any other members have any questions
any other members of prison right
do you have a question
we do yes it's uh picking up Mary's
point about knowing more about it I
think one of the questions that we asked
in the consultation was should other
adults in the house contribute towards
the council tax bill
was an interesting question and it kind
of came back two-thirds yes one-third no
and I don't know what kind of impact
that would have and whether it's
feasible to do it
or not so I think if that could be
included in
the further knowledge
seeking for this particular
issue would be useful
um just to say that the current
incumbent scheme takes non-dependent
deductions into account with this scheme
and seeing that there is continued
support for household contributions
where those households have earnings
there would be an expectation that the
second members contribute indeed where
those customers are in receipt of full
Universe credit would normally passport
to 100 where they have other adults in
the household who are working they could
would also be expected to contribute
right okay so um
does anyone wish to say anything members
of the cabinet in debate on on this so I
know I've heard from councilman crawl
which is fine uh councilor Osborne
in this recommendation I'm glad we're
going with this it will certainly free
up resources in an already pressed and
uh hard put shared Revenue partnership
and it will free up resources to deal
with other issues such as the cost of
living crisis so I'm really glad this
has come to cabinet and I do hope that
the cabinet prove it today it's got my
full approval thank you Mr chairman
thank you
does anyone else wish to say anything
Council Busby
it's referring back to the mid Suffolk
cabinet meeting this morning I know
there was some question from them as to
whether
it's going to be more
yeah
just whether there was any
additional recommendations that they've
brought in that might affect us going
forward I was I was going to mention
that because clearly one of the drivers
for this is is the the current cost of
living crisis and coupled with the fact
that
the scheme as it currently stands is is
difficult and costly to implement
um obviously we're only looking at this
for one year but
um
but that's that's
purely uh I would say more of a
technical matter more than anything else
because the issue of um uh cost of
implementing the scheme would would
still um apply in subsequent years so we
might need to consider this as more of a
longer term
uh decision rather than just one year
but certainly Melissa yeah yeah um so
the scheme once we make the change will
be there indefinitely so if we want to
make a change next year we would need to
undertake a consultation again so we can
keep the scheme under review during next
financial year and then take decision as
to what we want to do for 24.25
councilman Crowe I would just add that
the shared revenues partnership
almost certainly be monitoring progress
in this as we monitor absolutely
everything else
two members
and the shared revenues partnership as
to the other two councils and it's um
yeah it's pretty pretty um closely
covered and followed
a quarterly basis so doesn't hang around
okay thank you any other comments from
anyone
in which case
um we've had a
the this this paper proposed and
seconded and that um the recommendation
is for option three so I'll now ask the
governance officer to conduct the
electronic vote please
thank you that is seven votes four and
that's unanimous chair
thanks Henry thank you moving on item
nine paper BCA 2239
fees and charges for 2023 to 2024 I'll
now invite the cabinet member for
finance assets and Investments to
introduce the report councilor Busby
thank you yes uh you've got a full
report before you of all of the various
charges uh
and fees that we make
the proposed changes from this year to
next
we've conducted a very thorough review
with each of the managers responsible
and they've come up with what they think
is the right charge going forward in
some cases this may mean that it seems
as though there's a big interest but
increase rather
but that's
usually down to the amount of work
that's necessitated to deliver these
particular Services
all I'd ask you to look at is in fact
despite the fact that it looks like some
of the fees and charges are going up
significantly in fact we're going to
actually bring in less money overall
than we did than we will do this year so
despite those increases we have to put
look at the fact that the current
economic environment is likely to impact
us on some of the fees and I think the
most important page of the report is
appendix B on page 53
where you see the fees and charges by
service and in fact
there are so many of these Services
these fees that we set don't really have
a material impact on
the district we don't have many zoos
Etc and if you look at appendix B you'll
see that there are only three or four
really significant
areas where
the increase or decrease will make a a
significant impact
so
I'm happy with these figures and I'd
like to propose the recommendation
on your paper that we accept them thank
you
thank you thank you councilman may I
have a second to please
some McLaren
right members of the cabinet does anyone
have any questions
councilman Clara and then councilor
arthi
thank you
oh it's just I was interested in
pavement licenses
um a matter of Interest really
um I was amazed how cheap it seemed
but what the service they were getting
but during the pandemic pavement
licenses were very prolifically
um required because pubs and cafes and
and I was just interested if that was
still the case that we had the high
application list for pavement licenses
I don't know the exact number I think
it's it's certainly less than it was
during
um in covid and I think we actually
uh took away the licensing fee for the
during that period as well so because we
actually encouraged people to get out
and about
um and that's one of the reasons that
the licensing fee is not that high for
for Pavements because we want to
encourage
uh the growth and health of town centers
primarily so it would be ridiculous to
charge too much for that
I think the paper and license fee is 80
pounds isn't it
um
my boss bait is about taxing
no
Cabinet member for taxi licensing
is councilor Marvel easy I think
oh sorry
yeah it's it's with speaking to my
colleague behind
speaking to the microphone sorry I
wanted just to ask the question about
you and I have discussed this but I
wanted to do it publicly about the taxi
licensing as we're discussing licensing
um
you know it was brought to my attention
a few months ago about
students with special needs in Sudbury
not being transported to school because
of various problems with the taxes
right but but it was brought to my
attention because it was under Health it
was
but it was brought to my attention
because it was having an impact on the
health
okay and so I raised the question
and we have addressed it and we've um
the licensing team have met with the
taxi providers and County
because it has to be a tripartite uh
understand that thank you thank you
are there any other questions
councilor arthy
it's a quick one thinking about
consistency were these agreed by
mid-suttle this morning
uh I guess they're slightly different in
some cases they are slightly different
yeah
councilman Crawley did you have a
question not a question I was just under
the information I know that in reports
and our own press release stated that
Enid Suffolk will be raising their fees
differently because they're a separate
Sovereign Council they can yeah exactly
um other members present to a councilor
um who we're going to go to first
because I think I'll go to the chair of
overview's scrutiny first castle Hinton
thank you Mr Jim thank you uh just a
couple of quick points firstly to say
that the
uh charges for
pre-application advising planning is a
subject that is coming before the review
and scrutiny committee for
scrutiny in March but in the meantime
I'm also looking at on page 50 of the
report it talks about high hedges
as a flat rate at the moment and then
moving on to a rate per linear meter
which gravity means that you've got no
idea whatsoever how that is going to
affect the charges and
how are we monitoring value for money
for that because I do have one
particular case where somebody paid in
January
2022 to have a high hedge 30
or licensed or whatever removed and it
still hasn't had any response from it
other than lots of apologies saying
we're still looking at it we're still
looking at it we're still looking at it
well I think
put in that time so are we monitoring
sort of value for money on all of these
things where we're charging and how does
somebody figure out what the increase
per charge is when it's switched from a
flat rate to a price per linear meter
um
well that's an interesting question I
guess they use a tape measure
it's
I mean to be fair it's
is fair to be charging on a linear right
because they pay for what we do whereas
a flat charge it could be one meter that
they won't cut back or it could be 50
meters that it won't cut back
at least this way they'll pay for what
we do
I think we probably have to
um defer to get an answer to this at a
later date and let's Melissa do you have
any background as to that why the change
was made and um and the amount that's
actually been set per linear meter
whether that's there's any basis for
that obviously there is but yeah it can
so um the
the call out for you if you like is the
350 pounds and then I know the team have
looked at benchmarking across other
councils as well to see if it's fair in
terms of what we're charging as well so
it is a comparable comparable to being
proposed
okay thank you
just to clarify that Mr chairman so they
pay 350 pounds then an extra brake Pearl
in your meter oh that's interesting
because that yeah it doesn't doesn't
make that that doesn't come over in this
this report here um it's a bit like the
the public rights away where they talk
about
um a charge of per hour for sorting out
a puppet right away that's presumably
because it takes him
a certain amount of time to walk the
length of it probably right away yeah
the report does indicate that that fixed
charge was for the current Financial
Year and that has been replaced by
linear meter charge in the next
financial year if we can make that
that'd be brilliant thank you thanks for
that
Castle Barrett
um yeah just picking up on uh the
gambling premises and permits
you seem to be exempt from any
inflationary increases
I am exactly the same
obviously we obviously like gambas I
mean this is obviously our
to be honest we don't have any of these
premises but well we do we have betting
shots
we have Betty shops we have this we have
we have uh machines family entertainment
we have these things but uh none of them
have got any uh inflation or increase
and whether this is an oversight
because I'd have thought you'd have put
some increase on
because of uh just standard even if it
was just across the board as a block
seems to be a remiss that we're
encouraging inflation linked we're
encouraging gambling
um
again Minister do we have any background
because
which category the betting shops come
because this is referring to casinos
more than anything else
oh yeah so I was looking at the wrong I
was looking at the wrong page yeah
yeah
I think I think it's just
been
foreign
do you have any uh background to this
I I mean I'm not particularly concerned
about it but I just feel that we're
we're where you've got other issues
there which are less sensitive I think
and this is clearly um just a blanket
it's kept the same
uh why would that be when everything
else has had an inflationary type
increase
the monitoring officers like to comment
on this so um 50
yeah
um the way it should work is that um
because it's a discretionary service
because they're the fee rates are the
way they're meant to be set is in terms
of how how much you have to do it what
it takes to actually provide the service
we're not supposed to be making money on
them so year on year what you tend to do
is some one year you might make a bit of
money on it and then the following year
if you're then going to have a review of
the fees then you'd bring them down a
bit so it's all it's all about working
out what they feel I don't think v80
because I'm looking at some of the
others I don't think vat is even figured
into some of these figures they're all I
can't see that many having v80 added on
they've been worked backwards if you
like what's the cost of this providing
that service how much how many of these
premises do we have how many taxi
licenses do we have Etc
fee should be with a view to not making
a profit but with a view to covering the
cost of your service
because clearly
um as one of our budgetary pressures uh
is uh wage increases which are obviously
uh running higher than uh we have
punched into the past
and we've already seen that is the
one-off payment of 1900 or 2000 pounds
per employee and then the uh of cost of
living allowance so even taking that
into account there is the element of our
cost just by actually administering this
would go up so in all circumstances we
would be looking to cover those
increases of inflationary pressures uh
by doing that I don't make a big thing
of it I just think clearly this is an
oversight
I mean I think you were you were right
in the first point when you said we
don't make any money out of it I mean
basically as you said on appendix B this
year we're expecting six thousand pounds
we're budgeting for seven thousand next
year I mean it would probably cost us
more in all of the administration
changes
forms and whatever to recoup any of the
it's so small
yeah
it's the impact of what you do once
you've put the column up
thank you okay we're now moving into
debate so councilman McCrory
yeah and then Council Osborne do you
have your hand up
yeah yeah I've been looking at the
appendix B which was recommended
by Dave and and I think that does
actually explain that gambling and saw
lotteries overall uh you can see the
budget is six seven thousand and the
increase is 15 I mean
so there is an increase somewhere in
there I confess that
volume it might be due to the number of
shops but overall I think we're trying
to keep this sort of Fairly strange
there's a lot of stuff in here which is
completely unchanged and if you go
through greatness for example
um
the
um
do
we go taxi and private hire licensing I
think
that the way through the list and I
think that's quite right because we
spent we spent time recent
ly examining all those charges and
higher structure and I don't think we
want to change them again and as I say a
lot of this is fairly common sense and
and if it's not identical to the
mid-suffolk it's
suffix
charging structure and that's probably
reasonable for the point of view of
I don't have a problem with these
charges they have been looked at and
debated and discussed on multiple
occasions by the cabinet in briefings
and pre-meetings so and changes have
been made
is there an oversight it doesn't appear
so on the basis of table B which I think
is probably the best summary we're
likely to get and it does show that the
grand total is a one percent reduction
in these charges many of which by the
way I know to I was writing about this
just yesterday that they
uh are in fact statutory charges we have
obliged by government to include them so
they're not all discretionary
thank you councilor Osborne
Mr chairman um first of all I want to
say that you know our offices do a great
job in collecting fly tipping and they
do it quickly and they do it without
complaint so I'm not I'm not playing in
there however I have been advocating for
some time now that the charge for bulky
items Collective is uh counteractive
we're all aware of the huge problems
that we have in baber with domestic fly
tipping and the impact that this has on
people's quality of lives and the cost
to the council as well I will be
approving this but I will continue to
Advocate that we take a more creative
and proactive approach when we look at
this actual charge I think it can be
improved I know it can be improved I
don't agree with it I will be voting for
it but I will continue to try and get a
solution to those issues I've raised
before thank you Mr chairman
thank you Council McGraw could I come
back on that yeah because I wonder if
anybody here has actually used the bulky
items charging collection charge
I have
two no and and I have to say that it was
45 pounds for five up to five items and
uh I collected five items other than my
garage without any difficulty at all
um I could have probably found six or
seven and when I'd been asked in my own
locality what I would do I'd say get
speak to your neighbor if you've only
got two find a neighbor with another one
or two and another neighbor you know in
the same street everybody's got
something they want to get rid of I mean
I'm just saying it's possible that you
break it down to five items and you're
looking at a 10 or an item
um even even with even with the increase
to 49 pounds 50 so I'm not desperately
concerned I do see your point the
trouble of course is that it does cost
money to send that van out there's two
guys have to load it up
um you leave it at the end of a drive or
outside your property and they do pick
it up on the day and the only problem I
will say is the booking system doesn't
allow for the opportunity to pick up
more than one of a single item so if
you've got two bicycles to take okay
there's no means of doing it you have to
find a way of telling them that but it I
think it works
thanks awesome did you want to come back
on it yeah without
risking getting into debate about
collection of bulky items and domestic
flight tipping I suggest you take a look
around Sudbury and say see all the
mattresses that have been abandoned out
you know it's okay for you it's okay for
me it's okay for most people in this
room we most probably can afford 45
pounds or the increase that it's going
to go up to but there are a lot of
people out there that can't so they just
fly to Pitt and it costs us a lot more
money to collect that unofficial flight
again than it does for collecting these
45 pounds but I'm I will have that
debate at that time yeah I I think in in
a lot of these cases it doesn't matter
uh what you charge how much how little
um people will will always Chuck things
away because that's the way they behave
unfortunately
councilor Busby and I I hope John that
we'll we'll tackle that partly with the
tidying up of the the states that we
have which we've started to do uh to
great effect I think and I think they
will therefore pay nothing for things
like that because we'll go in there with
a big
give people an opportunity to tidy their
their own new state up
councilman VC
[Music]
an operation in Sudbury where we sort of
had an amnesty and there was a vehicle
with a great big cage and people brought
their large items and that was very
successful and I think we were looking
at ways of expanding that so that
there's a sort of monthly clear up
okay
um
if there are no further comments on on
this um obviously these three are not
standing everything that people have
said about the fees and charges whether
some should
um not stay the same we should go up or
whatever
um these numbers have now been included
in in the budget calculations and we've
we are uh with a fair wind touch wood
we're going to be able to
um have a budget that uh cabinet and
Council will be able to prove uh with
with these numbers included so it's not
as if we
um we're in a situation where we we need
to make some radical changes to this in
order to to balance the budget so um uh
I'm happy that the numbers we've got
here
um there's a lot of thoughts being put
into them
the various service areas and I'm happy
that it's a set of fees and charges that
that will um
stand up to excrucially for the next
financial year
so
uh if there are no more comments then I
think we'll move to the vote
thank you chair that bill is now in
progress
that is seven books for that unanimous
Jam
thank you moving on then item 10 paper
BCA 2240 tenancy policy I'll now invite
the cabinet member for housing to
introduce this report councilor Osborne
chairman
policy set out how tenancies will be
granted and managed in accordance with
legislation and regulation in our
Council homes
the policy consolidates our current
working practices in tenancy management
and reinforces our commitment to
equality and fairness
policy is in line with government policy
for social housing
security at tenure has long been
established as a fundamental aspect of
council housing however in 2011 the
localism ACT provided social landlords
with the opportunity to issue a very
different form of tenancy tenancies with
lesser security and for a fixed period
of time by doing so the government
intended for landlords to review tenants
needs for social housing on a routine
basis and require them to move to
Alternative accommodation if the
property no longer met their needs or if
they no longer were considered to have a
need for social housing
meanwhile following the Greenville
tragedy in 2017 government policy and
the focus of the housing sector has
placed greater emphasis on the
importance of protecting the welfare and
well-being of people in rented
accommodation and in tackling policies
which lead to social housing stigma
our proposal is therefore to continue to
offer lifetime secure tenancies as we as
always as we have always done to support
tenants and their families to make their
rented property a home and enable them
to put down routes in their local
community we want to encourage and
enable our tenants to move to smaller
and more suitable accommodation when
their needs change on their terms and so
will bring forward a separate downsizing
incentive policy later this year this
policy is being created with the help of
tenant insight and will provide
incentives to enable tenants to move on
to suitable alternative accommodation
when their needs change
we believe this tenancy policy and the
forthcoming downsizing incentive policy
will make better use of our limited
resources
both portfolio holders and officers have
been working hard to develop this
tenancy policy and the context and
principles of it were more widely
through our all member housing briefing
on the 29th of November
we need to be clear that it is
imperative that we have such a policy in
place to ensure we are compliant with
the regulatory standards for which we
know there is greater scrutiny of the
management of council housing than ever
before
Mr chairman before I move the
recommendation I'd like to make two
comments on the report if I may in 3.5
It should read and will include so that
should be a change and in 2.4 I need to
point out that no decisions are
undertaken nor indeed a vote is taken on
recommendations go into cabinet to
cabinet at a cabinet briefing so could
this please be deleted from the report
I would now like to propose
recommendation 3.1 outlined in this
report thank you Mr chem speaker Council
Osborne uh yes that will be amended in
the report it is inaccurate
unfortunately so may I have a second at
least
councilman crawl
any questions from anyone
councilor McLaren
Mr Osborne
um
obviously I'm supporting this these
recommendations but linked to this more
rigorous inspection by the
um as I was reading the report is does
that have a big impact on our resources
in the housing teams and at the time
they may have to spend sort of looking
at this particular
situation as well as part of the
inspection
no um by having our last Deborah to
um reinforce what I'm saying but at the
moment no it would it would be the same
resources if we've got now if we stay
with a secure tenancy however if we were
to be decisive to move to a fixed term
tendency the resources would be enormous
and that would take up a lot more time
I I don't know if Deborah wants to come
on that one
thank you yes just to um second what
you're saying absolutely if we were to
move over to fixed term tenances it
would have a significant impact on our
resources and we would have to make a
business case for for more resources um
way we can use our existing resources to
concentrate on some of the um you know
the challenges we've got in in Building
Services at the moment
thank you Deborah
any other questions from cabinet members
other members present do any of you have
any questions counselor Barrett
is
should I use this one because it's not
my
that's better
thank you thank you um
yes I
sort of uh
learned in the summer that um
baber hadn't adopted fixed term
tenancies following the change in 2011
that councilor Oswald mentioned
um I don't know whether there has been
any light shed on that since then I
haven't heard as to why that didn't
happen
um but
um
I believe that residents who are
taxpayers need a bit of representation
here in looking at this
um and I
realize that the could be a financial
impact and a Manpower impact on adopting
fixed-time tenancies
however there is also a
resource impact if you just have an ever
expanding Council
house base
um
that should be offset against one
against the other has that also been
thoroughly examined
Council Roswell can you answer that yeah
on the first question in regards to
um did we look back on what happened
2011 and then 2015 yes we did we spent a
lot of time I spent many hours with
Robert and he and his team looking back
on what had gone wrong I think what
we've got to do is it was a decision
that was made that was never implemented
that's a fact however I think rather
than looking back we've got to look
forward and not spend so much time on it
now we have sought legal advice on that
that we went to and the legal advice was
in our favor on the way that we've
undertaken our duties
um in regards to sorry what was the
second of the taxpayer
you felt well it was um uh yarn the
analysis has been that there would be uh
an impact on the results
review people's future need uh the the
current tenants there's also a resource
impact of the ever-increasing number of
houses that that you'll go you're
anticipating you need because because
um people don't generally are encouraged
to to move out of them they they have
them for a lifetime so I wondered if
that had also been considered when
you're considering whether you could
adopt
five-year fixed term tendency
in terms of the taxpayer I think
actually it would be more of a burden to
the taxpayer because as we've just
alluded to we would have to take on a
lot more resources to deal with a
flexible tenancy and I obviously the
outcome of that would be most probably
to have to increase the council tax so
in that respect actually that doesn't
carry any weight in regards to
um the fact about people moving on
you're actually going to have a
situation where if they're in a tenancy
with a secure tenancy
but we want them to downsize they're not
going to downsize because why should
they downsize from when they've got a um
a secure tendency to a fixed term
tenancy so it actually has the opposite
effect I don't know if Robert or Deborah
would like to come in on that and
reinforce what I've already said
thank you councilor yeah I just do add
um
I think from the staff resourcing
perspective that wasn't the direct
um
the direction of the question but
um the uh the resources required would
be funded by the HRA budget not the
general fund
is correct from wrong here
he's more along the lines of the bind
not increase turnover in our
we are increasing our demand for by our
need for additional homes in the
district
okay
which part of it so approved we were
asked to approve an increase in the
number of council homes that we
we buy or
so as you demand outstrips thank you so
much uh demand outstrips supplies we
know housing will always be needed
a point with this with this policy and I
you know I think we're asking a much
bigger question about housing provision
in the district
with this policy I think the focus from
from
the previous decision around fixed term
tenancies wouldn't have generated that
churn that would have had an impact on
the number of dwellings needed and
still stands now so our proposal is that
we continue to offer secure tenancies to
tenants to protect their rights
I think that wants to come in there
thank you and and also um the the
evidence
um from from the research from
organizations which did
Implement flexible tenancies
um show that it actually failed it it
didn't work because people weren't moved
because I haven't reached that limit
where they could seek their own
accommodation and I think also there's
The Wider issue here in terms of
creating place what we want to do is we
want to create place we want to
encourage our residents to be proud of
where they live be proud of their
communities pay their rent and
we've got a better chance of doing that
if we give them a lifetime tenancy
because they they then become you know
and feel part of the community and
that's been evidenced in some of the
research as well
thank you Deborah councilman crawl so
it's on this subject of fixed term
tenancies and looking at the report if I
may at this point how long do I have to
wait till debate just come up as a
question I think I've got some pretty
much in debate now as a well I think we
probably are so let's look at the
with some peculiar reason they're called
flexible I mean that's like an oxymoron
to me never mind so back in 2011 the
localism ACT suggested um that we had a
power
um but by 2014-15 according to para 4.9
only 15 of social housing tenancies were
let on this basis
um the government made further provision
in 2016 however announced in a new deal
for social housing in 2018 it would not
Implement those Provisions at this time
and the social housing white paper
um to further criticize the whole
concept making tenants feel like
second-class citizens
landlords across the housing sector have
who've implemented them and now moving
back to the proposed action that we are
taking this isn't just us this is lots
of people and finally the government's
long-awaited white paper and I mean I
wasn't waiting in Mass
on rental reform published in June 2022
announced the abolishment of fixed
termed tenancies by 2030 so once again
we're ahead of the game here
um signaling the potential of an end to
the current
flexibilities provided and I appreciate
that was two prime ministers ago
um still I think it probably holds
effect so there has been considerable
shift
um I think the offers a point that it's
been found that this
movement to fixed term Tendencies hasn't
worked has been clearly demonstrated
over the course of the last 12 years via
their own actions regardless I mean on a
practical level it doesn't
so I'm happy with this
Castle Osborne
and what it was supposed to do it well
actually I must agree in theory it works
really well in practice it's a non-goer
it just doesn't work and as as alluded
to the rental reform white paper 2022
it's going to abolish it so we might
find ourselves in a situation if we did
go hopefully not with fixed term
tendencies that come a few years time
then we're going to have to abolish them
anyway so we might as well stay with
what we're doing it works well you found
in other authorities to work well and
we're ahead of the game and other
councils have found that it's been quite
cost quite expensive to move from having
fixed term tenancies back to secure
tenancies so we're much better situated
in the position that we're in
yeah I'd agree with all that it's clear
that the um
the flexible tenancy option has not met
with the success that it was that was
originally envisaged for at um 11 12
years ago and the government's realized
that and um and we're just now in the
policy we're just reaffirming that we're
going to fit in with that direction of
travel
um
I I think
from from our point of view uh I I don't
think we would have been in a position
to that we'd have offered many
um uh flexible tenancies anyway I'm sure
most of ours will still have been even
now the vast majority would still have
been um lifetime tenancies
um a question I've got for members of
the cabinet we have
um focused a lot on this lifetime versus
fixed term tendency matter but the
policy itself does have a number of
other aspects to it does anyone have any
comments or anything they'd like to say
on on the The Wider policy that we've
got before us today
councilman craw I'm pleased to hear that
we're going to be engaging further with
tenants but of course that's part of the
tenancy engagement policy that we've
previously passed that I was interested
to hear of the uh proposed could you
just repeat what exactly that was Jan
that we would be Consulting uh tenants
with at the end of the year there was a
specific matter that you referred to
that you've got a an engagement upcoming
and that struck me as professional
engagement will be engagement will be
continuous there was a specific specific
specific item that you will be doing
we'll be talking to tenants about the
proposed increase in rents we will be
talking to tenants and in fact I think
our director of housing has already
started that process so that when the
budget comes to full Council in February
we'll have some feedback members will
have feedback on what our tenants think
about the proposed increase that we're
going with there was a specific proposal
I think are thinking back to Cabinet
later this year or possibly the end of
2023 but anyway and the whole point is
that we are engaging with tenants we've
adopted attempts uh engagement policy
this just fits in with that
um because that was
separate from the actual policy
that was it and that's a crucial factor
in actually making the system work
lifetime Tendencies which should have a
provision for downsizing so that we make
the maximum use of our housing stock and
we can continue to develop it in the
future
okay thank you for that
um so members of the cabinet anything
else that you wish to say
um on any of the other aspects of the
policy introductory tenancies
um the ending of a tendency succession
planning that sort of thing
um uh that's that's all covered in there
in in detail so um
I think um unless you've got any more
comments so can I take that as
um your ascent and and approval of the
policy
in its entirety in which case we'll move
to the vote
thank you
that is seven votes four chair that's
unanimous
thank you
Right Moving on then the the next item
on the agenda is item 11 paper BCA 2241
scrutiny cabinet protocol and I'd like
to ask the corporate manager for
governance and Civic office to introduce
this report
and thank you
this protocol has been formulated
following recommendations from the
corporate peer review and is considered
best practice by the center for
governance and scrutiny
the protocol clearly defines the role of
overview and scrutiny cabinet and
officers to promote a culture of
accountability openness and transparency
and recognizes the key role of overview
and scrutiny as a key enabler within
that culture
overview and scrutiny committee have
already approved the protocol at their
meeting in November happy to take any
questions Jeff
thank you Jan well I would like to
propose this so may I ask for a second
of these Captain McLaren thank you
cabinet members do you have any
questions on the protocol
Council Busby
what are we going to be doing different
we
in paper to approve what we're currently
doing but
so actually we've put into
um
hard words what we're going to be doing
so we're holding monthly meetings with
the leader the leaders and the chairs of
scrutiny and we made that more
formalized for their their agenda LED
put into the Diaries and we discussed
what's coming up on the work program
um we're also making sure that we're
tracking our overview and scrutiny
recommendations and evaluating their
impact to see what added value that
scrutiny is adding and that's done in
the form of traffic lights and that's
published now and taken to every ovary
and scrutiny meeting and to the chairs
meeting so in in what we're doing is
that formalizing everything and making
sure that we're actually analyzing what
scrutiny is doing and making sure that
it is adding more value to the processes
scrutiny uh program the reviews and and
were carried out by scrutiny is very
much aligned to the corporate plan and
the outcomes that we would for the
corporate plan
I just think it's a bit of an Overkill
having monthly meetings between the
leaders and
the ons chairs older thoughts as you say
there's a there's a work plan and
we know what we would be looking at I
wouldn't have thought you needed to
discuss that between those two bodies
every month
um as to the frequency that we've we've
started off with monthly meetings
whether we have them every month or not
going forward but the point is that we
have the regular meetings
um to ensure that there is
um a good uh working understanding
between the leaders of the two councils
and the the two chairs of the overview
and scrutiny committees
we've not got much to do have you
thank you Castle BuzzFeed any questions
from members of the cabinet if
no council McLaren sorry
future
um John i i as an ex-jer I've got to
support all of this
um but
um baber
overview is scrutiny committee over the
last two years has suffered a lot of
extreme changes in membership of the
community and the Committees are in
other community
it's a
is there any thing in place that will
ensure that members are regularly
updated in planning on the planning
committee we have very strict rules
about what training committee members
have to attend and if they don't attend
then there's some sort of reaction to
that is it possible for that to be
considered for overview on scrutiny
thank you
so thank you for the question so um for
our cancer induction we're now looking
at a program which will form modules for
the overview and scrutiny committee
obviously at the end of the day it's
down to the group leaders who appoint
members to that committee to to
undertake for those members to undertake
to to attend those committee meetings
and that is a is a group discipline
um as officers we can only encourage
that but by having this process and
protocol
and making sure that overview and
scrutiny is focused and has outcomes and
does add value it's hope that that
councilors will see the value of the
process
um is there no more questions from
cabinet members I'll go to other members
present firstly counselor Barrett and
then I'll go to the chair of the baber
over the
Zoom wait yeah
because he wants to hear what I've got
to say uh well as as the leader of the
largest group I mean this is the
graveyard committee
rather than yeah okay this is the
graveyard committee which is the least
popular because of the least amount of
outcomes it actually produces
um so my question is you know for you
um how do you make it more relevant to
the council
because at the moment it's it's just the
um support system to the cabinet
no it's not the support system to the
cabinet and that's not what it should be
it's not what it's designed to be in
that's not what it is it's it's up to
the council to to make sure that the
European scrutiny committee does what
the council wants it to do because it's
the council's overview and scrutiny
committee and
um it's for Council to ensure that it
does carry out
its proper role its proper function so
um
uh
I I understand I understand that there
have there have been some see if they
get more excited then on the prospect of
something actually happening with
overview and scrutiny shall I
um I'll ask uh councilor hint do you
have any question or comment on this or
what I was going to say was that I'm
sure to councilor Barrett has read the
colored page 87 in the in the report and
if he looks under the column which is
headed up overview in scrutiny I think
he dances most of his questions
um in terms of how it's going to hold
the whole uh participate in regular
training to develop their scrutiny
skills and
provide constructive challenges a
critical friend of the cabinet's
engaging decisions and policy making
certainly it's up to the up to the
chairman and ultimately the members of
the committee to to challenge the
cabinet and to hold it to account and
therefore be able to report back to full
Council
the training the training that councilor
McLaren refers to in planning is
obviously it's a subject is free so it
has to be it's a it's a statutory body
as opposed to and you sit there as an
individual uh as opposed to obviously
this which is not a formal type of
training because it's only the council
looking at itself which it does very
well these lights looking at the fluff
in his tummy anyway
I have a very low opinion of this yeah
um
that really wasn't a question but um uh
we we are aware of your opinion but uh
so I'm moving back to the cabinet um for
cabinet members to debate this this
paper
um
any comments councilor mccrroll no
surprise there then yeah so you have
here present
current chair of overview scrutiny two x
chairs of overview scrutiny covering a
period of four years and the member um
for great cornard who happens to pain on
the record is having no time or effort
for overview and scrutiny he stated it
on many occasions even as the leader of
the joint largest group on the council
um is his his thoughts might be colored
by that pre-delivered pre-pre-idea he
has in his head he doesn't believe in
overview and scrutiny I have to say as a
former chair
just don't believe that it works right
however never mind
um I'm actually almost feel a little
guilty that we didn't do this before
although we did actually cover all these
principles and I've made these points
myself many times that overview and
scrutiny is a three-part point between
the cabinet the council and the
committee itself but obviously it's
important to add the officers into that
because the officers provide us with the
basis of the discussions uh that we have
to do and they are after all
um sorry counselor I wasn't aware that
we were interrupting each other
thank you
um however I'm happy to support this and
I'm also happy with the tracking plan
that uh
idea and uh and I'm happy to see that go
on as I say feel a little guilty that we
didn't do it before but then we did
things as we did them and I think we
improved things as they were at the time
regardless of what some members might
think
right thank you for that um
it's important that we do have an
effective overview and screwing
committee
um it's important
um for the council to have confidence in
the the administration it's important
for our residents to have confidence in
in the administration and we do need
to make sure that if there are any
deficiencies in the way the committee
operates that we we Rectify those so
that is seen to be working effectively
but I do think that um
by and large ovun scrutiny does work but
it works it can only work as as well as
the members of the committee will let it
work or will or in terms of the effort
they put into it
but the important thing here I think is
really as you'll see in the um the
things that each party will do whether
it's a committee or cabinet or officers
each one promote the role and importance
of scrutiny inside and outside the
council and that is that is crucial it
won't work if people do not understand
it if people do not respect it so we
need do need to keep that promotion
going to make sure that
scrutiny is the committee that it should
be
um and what the Constitution expects it
to be
and uh so I think this protocol does go
a long way to formalizing that and and
reinforcing that so I'm I'm happy to
which is why I propose it I'm happy to
support it so unless there are any other
questions or comments uh we're in
cabinet debate now sorry Council Barrett
you've had your question
um councilor malvisi
I think um I'm supportive of this I
think it's very good I think it's
providing everybody inside the council
and externally with a clearly defined
structure of what should be happening
and sometimes unfortunately we live in
days when now people have to have it
spelled out
thank you thank you for that any other
comments for members of the cabinet if
councilor you got any no okay we will
yes we will now move to the vote then
thank you
thank you chair the voters now in
progress
that is seven votes full that's
unanimous thank you
item 12 paper BCA 5242 risk management
Improvement I'd like to invite the
cabinet member for customers digital
transformation and Improvement to
introduce this report councilman crawl
thank you very much chair I'm pleased to
introduce this report
um as background in April 2021 our
external audit Partners TIAA undertook a
review of our strategic risk management
Arrangements they identified some good
practice in our risk management
framework and made recommendations to
improve including an updated risk
management strategy now this report
updates members on risk management
Improvement since responsibility for
risk was transferred to the policy
performance Insight risk and Improvement
team
in January of this year following this
change SLT agreed to adopt a whole
system's approach to risk management
known as the government's orange book
this government approach will help us to
improve the culture and Leadership of
risk management across the councils
in March 2022 the councils also received
feedback on our approach to risk
management in the LGA corporate peer
challenge report
one of their recommendations was to
revisit the risk management strategy and
bring it to life to ensure a more
effective corporate approach to risk
including Financial Risk
members of The Joint audit and standards
committee on the 28th of November were
asked to consider the effectiveness of
the revised risk management strategy to
deliver the appropriate risk management
Arrangements
the new strategy includes the main
recommendations made by the TIAA and the
LGA and embeds the government orange
book risk management principles
this recommendation to embed our risk
appetite will be reviewed further
following the May elections and embedded
when the strategy is reviewed again in
November 23.
strategies supported by an improvement
program to embed risk across the
councils establishing a positive culture
of risk management and continuous
Improvement
joint audit and standard committee
members raised that they would like to
see further Assurance in terms of
companies risk management
as a consequence a change was made to
the strategy at Section 5 under company
level to note that the company's risk
panel meets each quarter to review their
risks with the council's risk management
lead
company risks are reflected on the
Strategic risk register where required
going forward the annual risk management
report to jasc will provide Assurance as
to the company's risk management
Arrangements
joint cabinet reviewed the paper on
December the 12th and was supportive of
both the work to date and the proposed
news strategy
cabinet members with their
responsibility for strategic risk
management and approval of the joint
risk management policy and strategy are
kindly asked to note the progress so far
to improve strategic risk management and
agree the new draft risk management
policy and strategy aligning with the
orange book at this point I would hand
you on to Jane and Teresa who can
provide further information should you
need it
thank you councilman crawl may I have a
second to please
Council McLaren thank you any questions
from members of the cabinet
Council McLaren
yeah I'm a who who am I addressing these
questions to to Jane well to Aleister
first of all okay yeah okay right
um well I want to say to congratulate
Jen and Teresa on a very comprehensive
report
um that was very interesting to read but
risk management is everybody's business
and you did note that in your report
um that was what I was taught when I was
doing risk management
so how
are you going to make this
meaningful
to
staff and board members
I think the first instance is that of
course risk management is going to be
embedded in the culture of the entire
all the Glarus directorates and that's
where you'll most likely see it
expressed and the point at which members
are going to see matters of risk
management discussed well obviously
joint audit and standards committee are
going to
we've already mentioned there's an
annual report but in all other reports
where a risk assessment is made and you
know we've got the grid for the 16
possible places all members will see I
hope and I'm as they will a consistency
in approach to risk management and if
they read the the structure of it they
will able to be able to see how we
separate different types of risk and how
we arrive at what level of risk and what
the impact of risk might be previously
this might have appeared to be somewhat
subjective now it's defined for example
above a certain Financial level the
Financial Risk is assessed at a certain
point and we can we can assess its value
and then assign a number to it so
effectively I'm hoping that's how
members will see it primarily I believe
it will be a tool for officers in all
the directorates I don't know if I've
got that right Jane Teresa
yeah
um thank you but just clarify
um some of that so we're working through
um our senior leadership team
um and Cabinet in first place and and
Jazz will then be will also working on
Teresa's working can you tell me more
about how we're working with corporate
managers to integrate risk into all our
surface planning and further down in the
business as well so we've got this
management across the programs and
projects in addition to that and we're
working to embed risk into job
descriptions and role specifications
with HR currently and we'll also be
putting in through the member induction
and physicians may
um Pacific Trading for cabinet members
and for jazz members but other members
will be provided with and then the way
things around risk management so there
will be it's a whole program a whole
Suite
we're going to embellish
is everybody's businesses which exactly
why we've gone for the orange book
about leadership and culture
a question
one of the things that goes with risk
management is
um
the
um
feeling that people have about
what they're doing and how they're doing
it and so one of the things I wanted to
know about was how acceptable and
accepting is our whistleblower policy
because that matches risk management if
people are not going to
identify problems and raise them in an
early stage
I would like to know really about the
whistleblowing because that is important
of the star to understand how they can
access managers and directors if they
have some concern
about a risk and often risks are not the
big external dramatic ones they are
actually something that might be going
on in the organization so I'd like to
know that thank you I think on that side
it would be very best to get Jane and
Teresa to discuss that because in terms
of The Whistleblower activity which of
course then we hope will doesn't need to
exist but of course it's got to be
considered do we do due diligence the
whole point about risk management is
that we are doing due diligence in every
point every place where we can see that
it's needed so Jane would you be able to
help on this
um
yeah
um and and to say we've got a corporate
um whistleblown policy
um within HR OD that um staff can access
and through
um The Connect
um on the internet
um and get support from mothers and
elephant people
um it isn't fully integrated into risk
we can we can take that
just
and whilst personal blowing policies are
absolutely essential to all
organizations and we hope of course to
continue to create a culture where
people and can come and talk to either
the line manager or to a member of the
senior leadership team about matters and
which concern them
finished it
where you've got an embedded risk
management as a part of your culture
hopefully that demonstrates invest less
of a need
for whistleblowing to take place because
we have structures that take place of
any risk that individuals may fear and
and I think it's a transparent process I
think the risk management process
is as transparent as is possible as you
can see if you go through the full
details in the report and the papers as
we've looked at them for several months
in fact
thanks Scott McCraw any any other
questions before I move over to other
members
otherwise president do you have any
questions on this
nope
cabinet members then
back to debate then do any of you wish
to um
say anything in in debate Council Busby
yeah the four by four Matrix it doesn't
tend to lead to much movement
wouldn't it be better if you went for a
10 by 10 matrix then we could be
reviewing the risks on a regular basis
and everybody would be involved
I'm not serious I think I can answer
that seriously actually because back in
the day
um under a previous nice predecessor as
chair of overview and scrutiny one of
the things that my predecessor was very
keen on was exactly as you're suggesting
um the scheme he um recommended was a 10
by 10 grid as you've discussed
um at the time I felt that that was
unwieldy because it's difficult enough
to arrive at some of the what's the
difference between a two and a three or
a three and a four
um I did point out to him at the time
that his experience of a 10 by 10 grid
was based on Ministry of Defense
procurement
look how well that has gone in terms of
risk management I'm not aware of a
single Department of Defense Ministry of
Defense project which has come in under
budget or on time so if that's how
you're going to handle risk management I
must confess I have my doubts about such
a scheme I think we make the 4x4 work we
've made it work and it's understandable
it is easily understandable and it has
also got enough flexibility to cover
ranges of risk
I would tend to agree with that and I
think
um
it's it's appropriate for us and and uh
and and it is I I think with um this
strategy we've got here it's it's
something that
we know we've got to to do we we've
formulated it in in a very comprehensive
way
because
there are things that we do now
decisions we make projects we engage in
and
um other things we do where there's a
lot of complexity and there is a huge
amount of risk not just for natural risk
but but other aspects of the risk that
um are far more complex and and we do
need something like this to guide us to
make sure that we do mitigate the risks
that that will inevitably um uh faces as
we go forward so I'm I'm very pleased
with this I think it's it's good
any other comments from anyone
or shall we move to the vote
we'll move to the vote then thank you
that is seven votes four chair that's
unanimous
thank you
right the next item
Comfort break right now okay
we'll have a five minute Comfort break
foreign
as a confidential matter however the
paper has been redacted so there are
some sections which remain confidential
so if we do wish to discuss those debate
those or ask questions about those we
will have to go into closed session but
um if we can avoid doing that and have a
full debate without that then that would
be good
so having said that I'll ask uh now ask
the cabinet member for finance assets
and Investments to introduce the report
councilor Busby
Council approved the sale of the former
Lorry Park as a site for new facilities
to meet the growing Health and Care
needs of Sudbury it would involve the
Hardwick house and Meadow Lane doctor
surgeries relocating to the new center
as part of the wider vision for Sudbury
detailed planning consent was granted
last April and funding approved by
Suffolk and Northeast Essex integrated
care board
pending the final sign off by NHS
England construction work was due to
start the spring with a new Health
Center becoming operational next year
however
a final condition of the sale is the
practice doctors agreeing to lease the
building for a period of 25 years a
commitment that the current Partners
feel unable to make without an
additional break clause
a break clause which would be unviable
for the developers of Sierra PLC who
have already invested heavily in the
plans
this report looks at our options to
support the delivery of the new Health
Center and concludes that the only
viable option is for the council to take
a head lease of the premises and issue a
sublease to the Hardwick house practice
with break options after the 15th year
there would be some risk for the council
if this practice then operated the brake
clause
however this is mitigated by the support
of the Suffolk and Northeast Essex
integrated care board and our
partnership approach to delivering this
much needed facility for the residents
of Sudbury
we are joined today by representative
Summers care board who would be happy to
answer any questions but commercially
sensitive ones may need to be referred
to the confidential section of this
meeting if we choose to go there
and I'd like you to
I'd like to recommend the uh
recommendations we'll post the
recommendations thank you thank you
Council Busby
um I will ask for a second or is anyone
willing to Second councilman Paul
okay members of the cabinet uh questions
for oh yes as Council must be said we've
got um
that remains confidential
the dependence I don't believe so no we
just got we've got to discussing let's
say that's okay
uh sorry as as Council Busby um uh
mentioned we've got uh two
Representatives
um from uh from the ICB Daniel Turner
and Peter Whiteman here today and and
thank you for joining us uh gentlemen
today so members of the cabinet
any questions and I do want to keep
questions and debate very much separate
in in this it's um it's a very sensitive
um paper that we've got to debate here
today and decide upon so um
are there any particular questions that
you have that haven't already been
answered on on this
okay
um other members
of the council present do you have any
questions
um
the trampolines to frame a question
is quite difficult in the context of
what is being required the count the the
cabinet a bit to offer
um or to be are not beat on to vote on
so I would ask the chairman if I could
have a little bit of ledency on
where I am on this
I'll Grant user leniency castlebarrel
I'll try and keep it to a question but
it is a little bit difficult
um I will just go back I was the
original Ward member for uh
South Sudbury or Sudbury South and I was
involved in early stage with the
practice manager
for
Hardwick house in bringing forward these
proposals which they identified
the the site which was this site that
the council has agreed to sell and that
was clearly
slightly controversial because it was
not in any plan it was not any Forward
Thinking of the council to give up car
parking space in Sudbury bearing mind
car parking is a premium and it's
clearly a
a difficult thing to give up that car
parking space
but baby District Council as its
Community responsibilities Julie went
forward with this scheme and provided
I think
a very good opportunity for the doctors
to expand
so that's a little bit of History
what I have a problem with is this is
the question I sort of get to at what
point does a district council's
responsibility go into providing Health
Care Facilities
foreign
that is what we're being asked to do
it is
um
I don't know who can who can answer that
firstly Castle buzzword you want to pick
up on on that and maybe what you're
referring to at any point where there's
a break
[Music]
the baby District Council has done an
exceptionally good job in providing and
facilitating to the current position
I'm concerned that the the request by
the uh
ibcu I've used to be PCC but I've
probably been out of date on that
um
is not able to come to terms with the
doctors
who are a business in their own right
and that you know we've we've if a
business came to the district council
and asked for this in a normal situation
the answer would be uh on your bike
but because of the the provision of
Health Facilities which is important and
we recognize that as a district council
we have been over backs and actually
provided our own asset
to facilitate this what I have a problem
with and this is where I'm asking
where is the point that we cross over
from being a district council with
responsibilities to our ratepayers as
District councils to be then providing a
health facility which is under the or
specific International Health Service
and I think we were in danger of setting
quite a a a precedent which I don't
think is particularly healthy now I
totally understand
um
why we're doing this and why this
paper's here but I just feel
are we as a council almost acting in
Ultra various Way by Arthur shakes his
head which I'm pretty certain we're not
otherwise we've got this far so I'm
pretty confident that we can do this but
should we do this
but I think in terms of
we're not accepting responsibility to
deliver a health care
what we're doing is we're facilitating
those people that do have the
responsibility to deliver it to deliver
it but my my question would be
what difference is there between a
regular business which the doctors are
they are self-employed business
at any other business that came forward
with a super request that was in this
position that provided some sort of
social care some sort of other facility
say if Oxfam came along and wanted us to
do that there I mean I just feel we it
is getting very blurred and it's
dangerous territory
and I think uh what I would what I feel
uh deep down as business owners
a standard 25-year lease is perfectly
acceptable on a purpose-built brand new
property which you are getting
um what part of it do they not feel
comfortable with and then asking us to
take the 10-year risk
well I think this is the the
complexities of the the relationship
this is my question yeah it's at what
point do we say no we've provided what
we've provided we've gone over and above
which what what we normally do
I think the the business owners need to
stand up and be counted
well
this is
I think
comparing it to any other situation that
you talk about
we would only be entering into this if
we had Total Comfort
the situation wouldn't would not arise
after a break Clause that we would be
left holding the lease
I accept that and it has to be part of
good working partnership with the NHS
there has to be an element of trust okay
so I take your point on board totally
why is that not that trust not from the
people who are directly employed by that
trust
by the NHS so the doctors do not feel
confident that we we feel confident we
could go to the 10 years but they do not
thank you Council Barrett um I think
I'll be quiet now no that's great and
and that will be fed into the the
cabinet debate uh councilman Melanie
Barrett did you and I'll come to you
councilman crow in a moment we'll come
back to the cabinet but just finish off
with
um thank you chair um I'm very grateful
that we've got been joined by
Representatives uh here from the NHS is
that right
um because they might be able to answer
this
um what is the period of lease that um
hhgp currently have in Sudbury in the
current base I think that is relevant to
understand in relation to what's
proposed here
do we haven't answered that they've got
several premises so presumably they have
several different lease agreements
depending on on which surgery we're
referring to
until I reply we do know but we I think
we feel it's that's a piece of
information for the practice uh that we
would cover in the closed session and
we'd be really happy to answer that in
the closed session because it's a
commercial matter uh within the
partnership we just because it's their
information I'm just nervous to to
introduce that to public domain
I'm really happy to answer on on in the
in the close if that's could we make it
simpler could we say
roughly
how many under 10 years are there out of
the number of
Arrangements that you have we don't want
to know details of which ones which
relationship you know which are rent you
have with which particular practice and
which particular location but
roughly
how many of them are under 10 years and
roughly by how
So within their existing premises they
are roughly under 10 years
they're existing stay
and they're roughly under 10 years
without existing estate
they're roughly under 10 years for their
existing premises
what I meant was when it was originally
signed what length of period was it for
I don't mind I don't want to know how
long it's got to run for
oh that that's a different question
um
yeah I don't know how long they've been
I'm I'm not familiar enough with the
hardwood house practice
yes
can I ask us like can I answer a
slightly different question is that
possible because
um yes you can if it helps so I think
it's a really important part of the
context to understand that um it was
common practice for general practice
surgeries sort of 10 15 20 years ago to
enter into 25-year leases they would be
quite happy to do that because of the
climate that the NHS was operating
within with regards to the certainty of
the future of the national general
practice contracts and it's that
uncertainty that is has led GP surgeries
in lots of areas to be uncertain about
committing their own personal liability
uh in Into the Future as their kind of
predecessors might have done and so it's
that it's that it's that context that's
changed that might be part of your
thinking behind would they have entered
into 25-year at least 15 years ago they
might have done because the the
commissioning climate was was different
and what we are doing as a as an
integrated care board as we've set up
the papers is to say it's our
responsibility as a commissioner
to pick up
should they leave those premises we will
pick up the responsibility of finding
another provider to operate from those
premises in future that's the
okay
um thank you before we do move back to
the cabinet I do actually have one
question myself which I should have
asked a few minutes ago
um
what can you explain and it in detail to
to members present exactly why
um the ICB NHS or whichever how you want
to describe it can't take on the
headlies themselves
why it has to be the third another third
party
so
the NHS entered into
um ifr16
sorry April 2022 which is an accounting
standard and the way the NHS accounting
um set up we are given organizations are
giving Capital allowances and it's
called CDL
when you enter into a lease under IFR at
16 you have to capitalize the value of
the lease over the duration of the lease
and that comes off of our Capital
allocation
so if you had a lease example for a
million pounds a year for 10 years you
would have to capitalize 10 million off
of your immediate pseudo limit
the way that's been brought in
we don't have to see the CDL
to cover that and the national team are
looking at that at the moment so you
don't have the what to cover that we
don't have the capital allocation to
cover the changes under the rfr 16. so
this is a relatively new restriction
prior to that coming in you would have
been able to do this
prior to that part of the NHS may have
been able to but at the time the
clinical commissioning groups which
precesses the integrated care board we
weren't allowed to hold the state
so when it was a ble to prepare trust
Primary Care trust at Holy state
they were abolished in 2012 and the
clinical commissioning groups were
created that the ability to hold the
state was taken away so other other
parts of the NHS that could do this not
necessarily the ICB but any other parts
of the NHS that could take on the head
lease so ifr16 wasn't an issue then yes
there would have been so a trust could
do it but with ifr16 that covers the
whole of the NHS so that covers the
trust as well as the ICB which is why we
have situations where where agreements
have been set up in the past such as
with the Constable Country Medical
Practice in East burgol where the NHS
has taken on the head lease and there's
a sublease for the GP practice there but
that's no longer possible now is what
you're saying
the current time
thank you
okay
um back to the cabinet um councilman
crawling and Castle Osborne
thanks chair
um
I'd like to ask or direct my questions
to the representatives of the NHS ICB
whatever whatever alphabet soup you're
using this week
as I understand the the leases on the
former practice buildings would have
been um I imagine most practices not
always purpose-built on private housing
converted for surgery use
I don't think they're directly
comparable with at least for example for
a purpose-built unit which is not
designed just to be a practice
but also to be a local Health Center a
center of excellence a center for
training a center with certain
facilities that a normal practice would
not have
all of that says to me that there is a a
facility that's made for a purpose that
I cannot imagine in 15 years time
those practiced buildings will no longer
be being used there won't be somewhere
else for the
HS whatever form it might be taking
whoever's providing Health Services is
going to need to be somewhere why would
they not want to be and a purpose-built
system operation for exactly that
blindingly obvious thing to do and there
would not be anywhere else to go at
short notice so that gives me some
security what I was hoping though was
that you could provide us with some
understanding of how the NHS
is going to work in 15 years time as
your best guess I mean there is going to
be
without doubt requirement for health
provision in Sudbury ants covering great
cornard
have you any thoughts about where else
you might go have you oh I mean you've
got some confidence in your letter of
comfort although not legally binding is
actually a letter of common sense to my
mind because what else can the NHS do
whatever form it might take could you
just expand upon that and see if I've if
I'm moving this in the right direction
because I think this is the issue yes
there's a risk
how severe is that risk and this is the
game is it worth doing this because of
the well the outstanding need for a
medical services in Sudbury in great
cornard which isn't going to go away so
could you expand on that
absolutely thank you um and just before
I ask I just I think I just want to go
on record as saying thanks to the to
council colleagues for considering this
because I think it's we this isn't a
position we want to find ourselves in
and in other parts of the country the
easiest thing to do is to sort of walk
away from the scheme and so I just I
just want to and I appreciate it this is
a challenging a question that you are
are considering something that which may
help and I've been working in Industry
since 1990
um and when we have a number of
reorganizations which is part of what we
constantly do and I've been party to and
the statutory responsibilities that each
Authority has passed on to the successor
body so we as integrated care board pick
up the statute responsibilities of our
predecessors and we currently have this
a statute of responsibility to make sure
that primary care services are made
available to the people in our
jurisdiction and in this care in this
case the Sudbury population so we must
and we're such a required to make sure
there is primary care services available
uh and therefore we need to make sure
there are facilities in that Community
available and as you quite rightly Say
by entering into this long-term lease
the only practical option for the place
for those services to be provided is
from within those premises and
furthermore should the existing contract
doctors hand the contract back we can
make it a requirement of whoever wants
to hold this you know a lot of money
from this NHS contract if you want to
hold this contract and provide Primary
Care in uh in this area you must operate
from these premises we can make that a
requirement therefore you know as close
as we can get to without actually saying
we definitely will because as soon as we
will within the all of the CDL kicks in
it becomes our asset uh
is proceeding quite what former NHS were
taking 15 years we could probably all
have a good good guess at that what I
think we can be as sure as we can be is
the statute of responsibilities continue
so that that is the thing that is
consistent through these different uh uh
reorganizations that we are undergo over
time
so
there's a stature showed responsibility
on behalf of the NHS that doesn't seem
likely to change
be something statutory secondly
the service providers of Primary Health
Care they are financially rewarded are
they not
in fact some people have said a variety
of things about those I'm not going to
go into that but there is a financial
reward for anybody providing Primary
Health Care and there's a perfectly
perfectly purpose-built facility going
to be available and its lifetime is a
great deal longer than 15 years I think
I think the risk is minimal and worse
taking I appreciate I think it's worth
it because the people of Sudbury deserve
no less
thanks councilman crawl councilor
Osborne
my question is directed to our visitors
smiling face
nice to get that when we go in the
surgery as well
um yeah it's away from the lease you'll
be pleased to know and it's actually
about
creating new jobs you say that you will
be creating 20 new jobs now we we are
all aware in this room and Way Beyond
the issues that you've got in recruiting
and retaining staff medical staff
so what makes you so different that you
feel confident that you're going to be
able to get these 20 additional staff in
places when you're already struggling to
retain the staff that you've already got
I'd like some sort of assurance
on this actual
um question please thank you
so I think the
um it's it's a seller's market if you're
a doctor or a nurse or a paramedic you
get to choose where you want to work and
so we need to provide a great
environment for staff to live and a
great environment for staff to work and
what a good premises does is Achieve is
exactly that so that's one of the
factors and also being part of larger
Health Centers so professionals could
support each other so at coffee break
they can ask each other I've got this
difficult issue or can you support me
with or I visited this patient yesterday
or I didn't know and so these these
larger Health Center premises facilitate
environments that where health
professionals want to work because they
can provide good quality primary care
because they can support each other and
it's that
uh it's a it's something it's not a
guarantee you know but but it means that
when Sudbury is competing with other
areas and with those uh professionals
who are choosing where to settle um
so you an asset to attract people uh
into the community to work and and stay
working there
so there is a slight risk there isn't
there that you all have this brand new
beautiful building and the benefits that
it gives to people in Sudbury but not
there is another risk today isn't that
I mean I think
I think it is a risk but remember we
have a statutory responsibility to make
sure there's a good quality Primary Care
Services there so if they're struggling
to recruit then we would need to get
around them which we do from surgery
from time to time to think about how can
we resolve it and we had a surgery uh in
Glenn glensford thank you uh where uh
yeah they exactly a circumstance where
the local practice couldn't manage it
and the hospital has taken over and
they've used their kind of buying power
if you want to use that term to to cover
off the workforce so the workforce is
what is needed for this population uh
and I think it's it is a risk but again
the contract value in terms of the
council's position would I don't think
it would affect the council's position
it's more us as the NHS commissioner to
make sure getting satisfactory services
but that exit risk exists anyway
whichever whichever building
is built about how we make sure that um
those services are are provided to a
adequate quality when we ask
commissioning and when the CQC inspect
the surgeries
Council McLaren and then councilman VC
a new hospital well we hope we're going
to build a new hospital get the money
um but modern hospital care is
becoming is enlarging into satellite
um
clinics and things like that and this
proposal is actually going to provide
some of that so in some ways this
development would be a confirmation as
as to hospital Services contract
um this we have to have these sort of
services within our communities
and we just absolutely yes I think is
the answer that the
um hospital is being built on the basis
that things that can be done in the
community that come into the hospital
now in future weren't they'll be done in
community settings and great premises is
a key part to making that happen so this
is one this in a sense we put help us
solve the Sudbury question we then have
to think about how we you know work
around the other aspects of West Suffolk
to get the equivalent facilities really
is this key part of that strategy yeah
it is in a line with modern Healthcare
Healthcare is going to be totally
differently provided to what we've all
been used to absolutely yes thank you
foreign
thank you Mr chairman
um
I'm a bit confused because you kind of
contradict yourself
in saying that you need to have a good
facility all singing or dancing
doctors are only willing to sign a
15-year lease
most doctors signing into a practice
around about 40.
they've done their training they've done
their practice and they're now in a
position to
settle down
so they'll be looking to retire at about
50 between 50 and 55 that's the end of
their lease they've got nothing to sell
they've got nothing to sell
so I don't know how the NHS
can turn around and say well we'll
change the capitalization on things when
did that happen
how recent was it
because no businessman in their right
mind will sign a 15-year lease
and make a huge investment
so I'm I'm confused because the
arguments you're presenting
don't wash with me I'm afraid
and I I live in a village that is going
through this pain threshold trust me and
it's not pleasant it's not nice and it's
causing a lot
of
very deep-rooted resentment
and very deep-rooted angst
as to how they're going to turn the
surgery around and deliver
and I'm sitting here and I'm thinking
well you know
the electors haven't got the benefit of
sitting here with me and listening to
you
but they've got an inbelt an inbuilt
radar of concern so I just don't see how
you can square this round pole
are you able to provide some something I
think so I'm just I'm trying to distill
the question I think the um
I mean it's just just just to get some
basic facts across um so the doctors
don't but any of you probably know any
of their own Capital into this project
the capital entirely comes from Ashura I
mean I I'd love to have had a job like
the least
that they take on is reimbursed by the
NHS but what they have is they have a
liability for the lease and their
concern is and a lot of this relates to
and this is generic please I'm not
talking about this practice because I
think that's that isn't appropriately
situation and this is a generic concern
it's a lack of confidence in the uh NHS
England and their rules they're setting
for setting National contracts for
general practice that that's what the
root of the concern is is that uh what
will be the future to that's what those
terms have determined what if I want I I
can't live within those terms in the
future yet I have got a 25-year personal
commitment into the future that that is
at the heart of this uh and it's that
and it's that it's that lack of
confidence and that climate has changed
I think in the last
um 10 years and both uh lots of
different um
parties even at the weekend we've had
people saying actually we should do away
with independent general practice we
should do we should move to a salaried
service all of which are valid arguments
but if you're an independent contractor
trying to think about taking up that
personal liability they're all that
that's that's at the heart of of whether
some of this concern comes from but
meanwhile you know what we're trying to
do we've got a we've got this
great
scheme on the table is the right Modern
Health Service solution and it's trying
to navigate through this uncertainty and
and I think it's a um hence we're to
collectively uh sort of wrangling with
this to find a way through so um and I
think the the building is obviously part
of what the quality practice needs to do
and I'm aware of your local surgeries
concerns because we've spoken separately
and that's obviously another big part of
our job is dealing with lots of those
issues uh where they arise um with
surgeries I'm not sure if the health
chair but I
thank you councilman curl I just want to
ask why did NHS England decide on such a
silly policy as IFRS 16. I mean why on
Earth because without that we wouldn't
even be discussing this and frankly it
sounds to me as though somebody up top
needs
lead to the council whatever decision we
make
should state that somebody upstairs in
the NHS in NHS England should re-examine
the adoption of this
counting regulation given the size of
the NHS given the size of its capital
projects across the country to nitpick
that affects an individual location so
easily as this
silly
yeah I I agree it's um they're clearly
some failings somewhere along the
organization that really need to be
sorted out because it's
it's
policy
thank you
does anyone else in the cabinet want to
say anything councilor Busby
yeah I've got a couple of
kind of off-the-wall questions if you
like which I think bathroom may may be
able to answer
um
what happens if Babe emerges with
mid-suffer and baber disappears
and we have heart of suffer does our
responsibility stay the same now
so if any councils cease to exist for
any reason then their successes would be
inherit any contractual arrangements so
that the contract would simply transfer
to their successful body okay and we're
saying it was similar with their unitary
structures for example what's happened
yeah so Sudbury were to end up in West
Suffolk after a unitary
then it would still be baber's
responsibility
no that potentially at that point and
potentially will be able to split the
two out on the basis that it would go
with the contract would go with the
place and the place if it were in a part
of another local Authority area would
then be in that area not in the rest of
the areas that were but essentially the
contractor requirement linked to local
government stays in one way shape or
another
and then
okay so let's get to a situation where
we get to the 15 years and the break
Clause has been uh called in we're still
committed to
The Headless so we're still paying the
amount that we pay out
is fixed
with
assume
when we get if you've called the brake
clause and you then bring in somebody
else
after the 15 years
are we at Liberty to renegotiate our
portion
the
lease so that the sublease could
actually generate a profit to Baylor
that's probably wrong for Emily isn't it
yeah
and then there would be a sublease below
that which would be very similar term
um but with break Clauses if the break
Clause was implemented then the um the
lease that we have in place with Ashura
would remain the same it wouldn't change
it would be subject to review in the
normal way and in theory you could
renegotiate
um
create a new lease with the new incoming
tenants however that lease is going to
be similar to the same kind of rules and
regulations that the current
proposed sublease is because
funding mechanism that or reimbursement
mechanism that's in place for for
doctors so there is the potential for
change but it's likely to
be along the same lines as the current
structure unless there are further
reorganization in how the system is
managed and within the
um
terms for the at least for the center
there is a clause that would allow the
lease to be terminated by the council
should the rent no longer be
reimbursable by the NHS
Authority as well so if there had been
such a significant restructure of the
Health Service that GPS are no longer
sort of reimbursed for their rent then
that would give
um
the council the opportunity to terminate
their lease at the same time as the
subleases donated
no not into those circumstances if we
were able to
that's the kind of the last fall back
position is that we wouldn't end up with
a building that
we would have to start looking for lease
start talking presumably well before the
end of the 15
th I mean it'd be silly not to
so if I just answered that question so
yes all break notices have a notice
period so and that notice period would
be well in advance if the lease
the same I would say would be the same
for the GP contracts as well that there
is a notice provision so we would be
working with Partners at a an advanced
stage to make sure that you had
continuity of service and actually
council's perspective continuity of
rental income to make sure that any
risks were mitigated
thank you Emily
um
question another question from me
if the land that was being provided that
is being provided was not baber land
if if the practice had found another uh
parcel of land from uh owned by somebody
else maybe even the nhs's own land which
are owned next to the Scion Health
Center in Sudbury
would you still be coming to us to help
sort out this problem
how would you sort it out if Ashura were
developing on land owned either by the
NHS or by another party
I think the true answer is because of
the current capital control rules with
it's timing us making developments like
this of this nature so we we are we're
struggling if it was on NHS land we'd
need to live within the NHS Capital
limits and then we get into a queue
which is a very long queue with not
enough NHS Capital coming down it so if
if we have NHS land we're then
competing with many many many other asks
for interest Capital which is really
restrained or we're going to a third
party
on third-party private land and they're
asking for a 25-year lease and the
doctors again to cover the bank costs
and we find ourselves exactly the same
circumstances so those are the sort of
the the three questions under those
circumstances Emily
so so part of the reason we're being
asked to step in is so that we can
um
and kind of underwrite the value of the
investment of this property and so
a third party to step in would need to
be somebody who has a strong Covenant
strength like the NHS or like ourselves
so if an individual owned a piece of
land and that individual was asked to
step in they wouldn't be protecting the
value of the building and to ensure that
you've got a viable development what we
need to make sure is that the investment
value of the building the finished
product
exceeds by a small proportion the cost
of delivering it and that's what we're
really trying to do is create a
structure that helps to make sure that
the value of the building at the end
exceeds the the construction costs that
could only be done by somebody with a
strong Covenant such as you know local
government NHS other kind of government
bodies so it's unlikely that we'd have a
situation where a third party was asked
to act in this kind of way it really
does need to be someone
or a body with a sort of similar
standing to ourselves
so if it were land owned by somebody
else then this project would just
wouldn't proceed
we don't need to be the original Orlando
no that's a b to be the
um so they've come they've come running
to us under any circumstances
in any circumstances the fact that we
own the land just means we've been
involved in this project and for many
many years
um I don't think it's necessarily the
reason why we're having the these
conversations today
does anyone wish to say anything at this
stage so I got a few things I want to
say
uh
yeah we are yeah yes
I will allow you to say something else
if you wish to councilor Barrett
and then uh councilor Oswald
what I'd like to do is just have a quick
summary of Where We Are
because I think it's quite important and
I and I think this is where I have a
problem with this project so you've got
a doctor's practice which we have to say
is a business it is termed as a
self-employed scheduled D business
get some brand new
purpose-built
property
which the rent for that property is paid
by the NHS with no input so they've got
no skin in the game
which is unusual for a business
there's no Capital requirement from
those uh or liability to those
self-employed practitioners
they have a period of
stability of 15 years
we're there there
fully paid for by the NHS supporting the
24 000 people suffering and one thing I
think hasn't come across
which I think is worth noting
Hardwick house practice is in Sudbury
Sudbury is on the border of Essex half
of those people I would suggest
nearly half are from Essex
that use that practice just a point to
note
um
so the the people that have the net
benefit of this brand new facility which
is provided for by the NHS and funded by
NHS and then facilitated by ourselves
but they have no skin in it
and are not prepared to go to a 25-year
standard lease
I I just feel the uh the position of the
doctors is poor
I I think it's absolutely poor
they're there doctors as far as I was
concerned are there to provide for their
patients
to me at the moment it doesn't look like
they're very much in providing for their
patients
I'm not going to say what I really think
but I just feel
it's getting skews
I'm just concerned as a district council
this is my main
I mean I think at the end of the day I
think we'll probably do it because it's
the right thing to do
I think it's the right thing to do but
what worries me is what's the thinking
behind where why we're in this position
that I think is worrying
thank you Council Barrett firstly Castle
Osborne and then councilor Busby
okay gone I said it's just I think oh we
are not in the uh South Suffolk North
Essex Hospital trust the The Ice the
integrated care system covers so I don't
I just meant and uh North East Essex but
I'm not sure necessarily whether the I
just means
NHS is already operating across
boundaries
any number of patients are from North
Essex beaches which Council McCall
they're not likely to be Northeast Essex
and part of this uh integrated care
system
the yeah it's um different part of Essex
is that further west
councilor Osborne
thank you Mr chairman do you know I'm
really divided on this and actually
Council councilor Barrett has raised a
really valid concern
and I really see his point about us
being a district council and not a
health provider so you've got a valid
point there don't often agree with you
but I do on this one
I would debate that but anyway however
I'm also aware of the advantages that
this scheme will bring to people in
Sudbury and cornard
um
you mentioned that other councils have
walked away from similar projects which
is also a concern however
the risk to the council listening to the
debate today and reading the reports and
all the information before us is minimal
and although this is not an easy
decision I'm aware of the consequences
if we do not give this our approval it
will fail and I can't have that on my
conscience where we walk away from a
project that's going to fail how can I
face people when I say we didn't vote on
it so sorry you're going to have to put
up with the Hardwick house that you've
currently got and the lack of services
that you've got from that I can't go
with that so
again we might we make reference to it's
the right decision and I shall be voting
for this I don't know that necessarily I
completely agree to what's happening
because I can see the points that other
councilors have raised and it is a
concern why should we be taking on this
responsibility when actually it's the
NHS but we've got to we're in a position
where I don't feel we could walk away so
I shall be approved in this thank you Mr
chairman
yeah I think I'm responding to Simon's
the doctors haven't got us any skin in
the game come
which is the way I look at it the it's
not the doctors that have the
responsibility to provide doctor
services in Sudbury it's the NHS who
have the responsibility to so the
doctors I presume the NHS could
Sack or get rid of the doctors in
that surgery if they're not performing
and bring new ones in so that's why that
there's no
ownership of the building I think
my point is that it's it's
I think the trouble is it's very
difficult and it gets very emotive when
you start talking about doctor surgeries
because everyone gets involved but
actually if you need cold-hearted about
it and you look at it as a business
which it is
then that's where it's a different model
totally
um but one point which I've just thought
about which is um
could I Minister could you clarify
because obviously we we've got you know
that we're talking about this um
liability from the NHS on their eyes but
presumably we've got a liability in
taking on a lease so it would affect our
ability to borrow possibly although
we've got plenty of Headroom
but it could uh if you look at it it's a
liability on our balance sheet
is that correct
yes Melissa yeah um at the moment it
wouldn't be so it would be within our
revenue account so on the irs16 doesn't
apply to us until
24 25 so there would be a shift then
when it comes on to our balancing so
there would be a change
for us
okay um
Council McLaren
and I just
[Music]
and probably will change
if they become salaried let's just take
note it won't just be Hardwick house
group of practitioners that is going to
happen all over the country because the
GP contract was very secure for GPS it's
been in place a long time
it's changed a bit
over the time but you're right Simon is
a business
but
the threat to GPS is if they become
salaried so it this won't be the first
example where there'll be changes in the
provision of health services
wherever in the country thank you
thank you Council retirement
I guess I'm the coral I think it's quite
possible we could be debating this in
another half an hour's time should we
wish but I would like to propose that we
moved to the vote well immediately and
ask for a second I will in a minute I
just want to say a few words if that's
all right first
yeah
to hear councilor Barrett talk because I
think all of us
things that he's been
and it's not our responsibility and we
we get to a point where we have to
decide whether whether we want something
to happen and I
went to himself and that is
in order to support the communities that
we represent
we want this to happen
and in order to make it happen we're
going to have to do something that kind
of is a little bit contrary to the way
that we would have wanted it to happen
um only an hour or so ago we approved
our risk policy and strategy and this is
kind of what it's about
um you know what what are the risks that
are associated here I I think that with
Doctor surgeries we've got more problems
coming in the future with regard to cell
contributions as well because we have a
similar sort of train of thought going
with regard to cell contributions where
we require the applicant to have a
25-year minimum lease so I can see that
we might have issues coming there in the
future as well but I just go back to
really the point and that is we want it
to happen if this is the only way we can
make it happen then this is the way we
have to go I think yeah
cut some cruel on that point of risk
management if you look on pages 120 221
you can see the risk assessment as being
the likelihood being unlikely and the
impact being bad that as a score of
three I think pretty much is an accurate
statement of of just how normally
speaking I start to worry when we get to
six
okay
um
I think we all agree this is one of the
most difficult decisions we've had to
make
and on the one hand we do want to see a
new medical center on the other we are
now having to shoulder some of the
Financial Risk will be small admittedly
and that's not something that was
suggested at the start of this process
and some councilor Barrett has given us
some some background about five years
ago he started to talk to the hardwood
house practice to see if we could
identify land for the new medical center
and indeed I had a meeting with them in
Sudbury in January 2018.
now eventually the Lorry Park was agreed
and everything has proceeded with all
parties including Ashura in good faith
now the practice seems to have rewarded
Our Help by effectively holding a gun to
our heads by deciding that they don't
want anything more than the 15-year
lease
if we don't assist then there won't be a
new state of the art facility for
Sudbury
and Ashura would have wasted a lot of
time and money designing the center and
obtaining Planning Commission
just must have
been a start that they would have had to
commit to a 25-year lease I really can't
believe they were so naive as to think
otherwise
Council Barrett has addressed the fact
that the partners don't want this risk
well
welcome to the commercial World other
businesses do have to accept risk as
part of development and expansion
neither party is likely to be here in 15
years time the risk to ask or more
likely successor Council to baber is
still there despite the letter of
comfort from the ICB
and we know that doesn't really have any
legal validity
in 15 years time we aligned and you have
seen another NHS reorganization
so with the ICB successor on a the
letter or indeed any requirement to
mandate the use of the health center
have the other parties really explored
all other options or has it just been a
matter of we'll get the council to help
there'll be a pushover
they do seem to suggest that there is no
alternative and I think we do accept
that argument
so that does mean that the system is
completely broken at this at the moment
and no new medical centers can be built
until the present IFRS 16 blockage is
resolved
I I can't believe that we're in that
situation but it appears we are but also
I can't think other councils would be
happy with us for setting a precedent
it is for District Council to cover for
the failings of the NHS and the
privately owned GP practice
the ICB does need to work out a way of
supporting this sort of development in
the future
but it is the practice that I believe
has behaved badly and let everyone down
including its patience but what choice
do we have
we can't walk away
um we'd be letting Ashura down more than
anyone else
and as others have said we do we do want
this to happen so I think reluctantly
we've got no choice
it's it's awful that we've been put in
this position
the GPS really need to think and look to
themselves as to how they've they've
handled this situation I
I'm quite appalled to be honest but what
can you what can we do
unless anyone else wants to say anything
I think we move to the vote
okay
thank you chair the vote is now in
progress
members I think we might have to rerun
that vote there seem to be some
technical issues at the moment I'm just
going to rerun it okay thank you
yes I think let's just rewind about
please so we have a clear vote
we'll go for a show of hands go on
reluctantly for
yeah
thank you
okay
can I suggest that um
if you look at the letter from the NHS
the
the Northeast Essex logo is um wording
is can do Healthcare
maybe you'd like to
change that
okay
yeah
moving on one more item left
paper BCA 2237 to confirm the
confidential minutes of the meeting held
on the 5th of December 2022
um
I really don't want to go into
confidential session to discuss it so if
we're happy just to propose second and
vote May I have a proposed the
councilman craw may have a second a
castle McLaren
unless anyone really does want to go
into confidential session to talk about
in a minute then we'll go straight to
the vote
picture the folks found progress
hopefully
you're just missing councilor Arthur's
vote
certainly a counselor I presume that's
four so that's seven votes four that's
unanimous thank you
thank you everyone
um it's been quite a long meeting but um
we've got through quite a lot of
business today the next cabinet meeting
is scheduled for Monday 6th of February
at 2PM see you all then thank you